going all the way back to my childhood
it's the same thing right it's the same
reality that i had growing up where
if you're going to attack me
you got to know what's coming back
and as long as you know what's coming
back the next time you're gonna think
before you do it and all you need is the
thought
i don't it's not about intimidation it's
not about any of that it's about i want
you to know
because there are bullies in the world
and those bullies
they thrive on knowing you're not gonna
do anything
and so for me i kept i always looked at
it like well
you're gonna have to do something
because
you're gonna attack i'm going to respond
and now what
where where where are you are you really
the bully or do you sell wolf tickets
good luck which one is it
because if you're really the bully then
you're going to stand up to the fight
there are a lot of guys and you know
very different in nascar because you
have bumpers right indy car that y'all
don't play that right that's not a game
you play because that's people lose
their lives um in go karting you gotta
have bumpers it's open wheel but it's
bumpers so it's kind of an in-between
but you constantly you know especially
in the like you always get bumped in the
back
yeah that's an almost always case right
so um i just i i think just through life
i've i've just always been that
that fighter that wants to
live a happy life and i just want to be
left alone in that
world of like just don't attack i'm
never going to attack anybody
right i was like whenever i accidentally
bumped somebody at the end of the race i
don't care whether i ended up winning
losing
back of the field the first thing i
would do is walk up and go my bad just
immediately i'm letting you know that
was an accident that is not my intention
i was not trying to take you out i'm
sorry my bad how can i make it up to you
like that was always me because that's
just who i am yeah like i'm never the
starter of anything i'm always the guy
who gets
gets it takes it and then when i respond
people are like you can't do that like
what do you mean i'm just responding um
and it's just you know look it's it's uh
i think in life you wanna you wanna make
people recognize
to make the right decisions and make the
right choices and don't bully anybody
don't come down on anybody let's just
try to do this and have fun
i used to say to people all the time by
the way if you're racing next to me
this is not your career is it really
that serious
i'm doing this for fun and i'm not good
enough to make it to the top so
if you're racing next to me there's a
good chance you're not making it either
so let's just leave it and let's have a
great time let's respect each other and
let's keep going oh well i think you're
undermining your talent but so where
does where does acting fit into this
because like i'm hearing about like you
know boys and growing up and the banter
and the fighting and the racing and the
you know like where does acting fit into
this so here's a very interesting thing
that i that i've that i always look at
right
it all makes total sense to me acting is
the only
job
right
where
truly
second place is the first loser
only one person gets the job oh i see
what you're saying yeah okay so you're
fighting for the win
and nothing else yeah because nothing
else matters
the guy who
was going for my role who finished in
last place
and the dude who
just didn't get it and was the next
person in line
there's no difference
so the mentality of win or don't care
is how i live my life how i live with
everything i only know that you either
win or you're lost
second place doesn't matter
it's like
talladega nights when he says dad you
said if you ain't first you're last and
he goes
my stupid son he's like you could be
third or fourth or shoot you could be
fifth
you can i love those raising movies
they're so great greatly terrible but
but so so with the acting
right it was always about
winning it and i and i say this all the
time the the job
in the industry right your job is to
audition
that's what being an actor is
right you get it you get it
you if you get it
that's the bonus
right but the job is auditioning you
gotta learn your lines you figure it out
you create whatever it is you're gonna
do you go into that audition space
whatever it might be and you deliver
and if you deliver the best
you get the job now you get the bonus of
doing the work
right so
for me it was like i gotta go win today
right i gotta go win i gotta go be this
person i gotta become somebody else
today and
and i was very fortunate because i
literally worked from day one
the first audition ever went on i got
and so
i in my mind only knew you go to win
this you go into that room and you go in
you be whatever it is that you need to
be
right no holds barred whatever they ask
you to do you go do it
and you do with a smile and you deliver
and so you know i was fortunate enough
to
to deliver
on
you know
some impactful roles that um gave me an
incredible life and um and i and i feel
blessed and fortunate that i was you
know even put in the position to go in
you know and to get and to give myself
an opportunity to to win those roles
when when
um
i switched to a different agency many
years ago and the first
meeting i had with this agent that i
ended up going with his name was john
stovis um
and he he said to me
all i can do as your agent
is give you a chance to
succeed but you got to go succeed
nobody's going to do like we could be at
the bed with caa which is the biggest
kind of you know talent agency in the
world
we can't get you work
you get yourself work
we're just going to give you the
opportunity to get that work
and that's and that's the way i've
always looked at it's my job to go in
and deliver and you know with acting
it's just i it was easy for me to become
somebody else
it was easy for me to
you know
as as as we've gone through this
interview it's hard for people to
imagine that the person who's saying all
this
played carlton
right like it just
they don't equal up that's because i'm
playing somebody else i become somebody
i live that life i literally become that
person and i i i deliver what i think is
a comedic most of the time performance
of that person and and my comedy really
is
you know
people live
at like a six or a seven
on tv you got to be a nine or ten in
terms of energy you take it yeah it get
to the end of where it's almost too much
right and so you know i can't live it's
it i can't be on screen at six or seven
i gotta be at nine or ten
and so that's all i ever did i mean even
when i do like i mean i'm obviously not
full-on acting but let's say there's a
take for a commercial or anything you
name it like something little and then
they're like all right let's do one more
take well for safety which always means
that was okay but maybe there's better
in you would you like me to overact and
they're like sure and they always love
the overacting they just love it they
love the oh my gosh and the
dramatization and they love it you know
and it's like
because
there's that little person in the back
of our head that says but don't look
like a fool
right so you you you stop yourself short
of
being too big always
that is every person in this world that
is their instinct is to stop short
okay when did overacting and looking a
fool and being afraid you might look a
fool when did that pay off and you were
like i'm so you know there it is i'm you
know i i was worried but holy [ __ ] it
worked
literally
after
when i was on broadway
like
at 12
it was like
because
theater
musical
not a drama
i'm the tap dance kid
you've got to talk to that person
in row
38
you got to talk to that person and
you've got to figure out how to project
to that person while still being in the
role
when i got the tv
they all kept trying to turn the knobs
down it was always all right just bring
it down a little bit more just just a
little less a little i was always 10 10
right always and then it was like nah
let's i stole a seven in here every once
in a while
and i was like seven
you're like i mean anyone could do that
i was like look we're missing the point
but really but that but but then i
learned oh it's variety right you got to
have highs and lows and sometimes the
lows need to be here and sometimes
moments need to play incredibly true and
incredibly real and small and then
sometimes i need to play big well all my
moments on fresh prints
that are memorable are big moments
right they're 10 10 moments and
what i learned while doing fresh prince
would be
oh i need to go to the five
to allow will to go to the nine
so that i don't take away from his
moment
so sometimes the still
is
the setup for the big
ka boom
yeah i need to be the cup for his boom
right so so it's it's literally i
learned that as time went along but it
was literally from
first time performing in front of a
large audience was go big or go home